I don't want your kids feeling that
energy that nuclear reactor inside your
chest that's always kind of
buzzing that you don't deal with except
when it just overflows and becomes a
volcano in your living room I don't want
them Fe I I'm people worry about that
explosion it's not great right when
yelling and screaming and slamming
cabinets or whatever it is you
do but that's not what I'm more mostly
worried about I'm more worried about the
dayto day the perace the pervasive burn
it's always there that those four little
kids are wondering 247 I love her she's
so great she never blows up at us she
doesn't scream or hit us but she doesn't
feel safe